call me dude Z just for this episode
instead of segments I prepared a series
of prompts and questions for you to help
me make future episodes of doozy even
better please respond to them honestly
do you wear socks to bed
yes no sleep nude yeah I sleep nude too
but you gotta wear socks good for
circulation dude with socks yeah Jesus
nude with socks have you ever tried
telekinesis what telekinesis yeah not I
mean I think sometimes you know you're
sitting there and you're like can I no
not seriously I do it every day
seriously okay that's not true it is you
try to do telekinesis every morning when
I wake up I try to move the spoon that I
use for my oatmeal okay has it worked
yet no and finally have you ever
fantasized about being made of metal
yeah yeah yeah